god of thunder king khan  you have finally joined our fight well  they say better late than not alone  this is very nice  as you know we used to live in a  peaceful oasis but in our gods were  murdered murdered and now our sacred  temple has been left unguarded and  hopefully to control of its power it is  our most sacred shrine and it desecrates  not for long  king you can't  tell them what happened here today  tell us the time that four  drag tag motley crew misfit desperados  turn the tide in the battle and edge  their names in history the odds may be  against us but i'll tell you this for  free here we go this  and  here and now  [Music]